non parte non fa per te la mia quando
finiva male di aprirla devo andare a
prendere le cose mica partita il tempo
scopert 1t tin tin tin tin tin tin tin
tin tin
sono le 21 lorenzo si questa luce mi fa
troppo luminoso da rin l'arte come se
lei davanti a tutti merda è un solco
luminoso stavolta aspetta un po come gli
impegni a spegnere provare a si spegne
però a spegnendo peggio è più luminoso
di prima e come è possibile
aspettavo su probabili ciao ciao amici
allora sia stefano di cemento
provinciali ciao ragazzi ciao ragazzi
nascono al buio oggi quando quando la
ragazza che ti piace 10 si temeva è
allora mettiamo un po più di così così
va bene armati per le auto sono
brilliamo di luce divina perché noi
possiamo poi magari non siamo in live in
realtà hanno detto una cagata interrompi
6 milan dovrebbe sette ragazzi si sente
bene si vede bene ciao amici come state
perché non so se si sente non so se si
vede non so nulla quindi ho me lo dite
passeggiate o carreggiate va bene di
chiudere sempre l'audio dei video capri
sono gli si intima il celebre tre volte
le noci datemi sola conferma che si
sente bene io sono contento comunque sia
lorenzo sta facendo faville versus food
praticamente oggi e non solo non posso
mangiarlo perché sono a dieta
anche se in realtà votato comunque al
sushi però oggi ha cenato quindi questa
è una vera e propria tortura è la cia mi
sta torturando mi dispiace davanti ai
miei occhi la tua allora ordiniamo una
pizza
certo poi uccidermi pure il problema non
è questo che non ho mangiato
quindi o maggio in live di scusatemi ma
dall'altro non vedete le condizioni del
sushi un attimo tutti i migliori sono
rotolati allora mi hanno puntato sui
sushi il tizio che non ha portato il
motorino ovviamente si è schiantato
contro un albero e quindi se tutto il
sushi in avanti si è schiantato il sushi
andato di di fisica contro la passano di
traverso esatto
7 una nuova forma di arte dai capelli da
un'altra pupa dai comunque ragazzi oggi
giochiamo ad ars un pro nel mentre
mangiamo
perché io mangio almeno lui no perché
abbiamo lasciato in sospeso la nostra
sfida quella dell'avventura ti ricordi
che sul mio cane abbiamo fallito esatto
veramente ve lo spiego perché magari non
lo sanno ha praticamente cosa è successo
sul suo canale l'altro martedì l'altro
giorno sul suo canale rom in live e cosa
è successo siamo abbia provato a fare a
giocare la nuova espansione di art co
balza in qatar indicarmi lo dico in
inglese ci ha insegnato niente
cobolli e catacombe di nuova espansione
cobol stanca con 100mila rai grazie due
centri 200.000 like è praticamente
abbiamo provato a fare la sfida con il
sul suo canale ma abbiamo perso
miseramente il compenso però abbiamo
sciupato 50
adesso faccio passo bat 50 bustine io no
quindi oggi proviamo a rifare la sfida
di dias sono però sul mio canale
ovviamente non la vinciamo vinciamo
guarda sono buongiorno così finché
questi giorni questo sì ma capace
comunque stai mangiando solo l'inter in
questi giorni mi sono allenato con le
carte nuove tra l'altro sono alcune cene
sono assurde e bellissima secondo me si
può fare oggi ce la facciamo
no ce la facciamo che proviamo il link
di ars on top e io vi lascio lì e vi
lascio il link dell'espansione diverso
già entrata robles anche the concert del
fiora qua sotto in descrizione caso
foste interessati persone gratis
comunque mi interessa io adesso aprirei
hurston pane professionali ragazzi a
transizione quanta 100.000 like allora è
arrivato il momento in cui devo devono
girarmi le balle e raven c
quando lui spacchetta trova le
leggendarie manco ciccio gamer il
problema è che io non ne trova ancora
come si agitano i partiti vogliono
sovvertire all'ato 2 per te 1 x men 2
per me uno per te se non trovo una
leggendaria tutte nell'iphone di corsa e
difficile sono solo tre bustine era che
c'era manco la rara ma troppo ma devo
che apra la seconda sicurezza bye bye
bye sicuro ma magno striscia negativa
secondo pacchetto io di bustine me ne
intendo
vedi darmi qualcosa di interessante qui
non ci abbiamo un bel niente
qui ci abbiamo una rara e se c'è già la
rara forse qualcosa interessante lo
troviamo
no no no dico io perché le carte
somigliano a le disse va bene
ultimo secondo me e nell'ultimo poi ti
ricordo che comunque sono gli obiettivi
che verranno altro quindi la troviamo
troviamo la leggendaria e speriamo 20
milani tace in mezz'ora strisce di
stoffa 50 bustine cosa l'ultima carta
raga l'ultima carta ci ho sperato per
lui sai che per un attimo ho detto no mi
dispiace nove ragazzi niente e ci aveva
provato come premiano susciti vabbè c'è
il sushi e iniziamo la band ma neanche
fossero stati 50 pacchetti avrei trovato
la leggendaria quello il problema
capitolino non le trovo io sono stato
pessimista non è che vedere il bicchiere
mezzo pieno vede il sushi senza il
cavaliere dai allora kobold hank atac
oms insieme riccobaldi e catacombe si fa
in ingresso più figo commons
diciamo che inizia e semplice dovevo
spiegare il gioco ma se mangiassi un
casino allora è molto semplice allora tu
dices sputando metà sociale tutti scegli
l'eroe io alzo zero
in questo caso il druido take that with
tempi ripete nosate news sono stati
scelti non a 6 restato che lo scegliamo
limite uguale ma york dove lato abbiamo
fatto dall'alto canale ma così però sai
giocare lui dov'è arrivato molto più
avanti perché sono le più stabili di
guerrieri però secondo me possiamo
vincere tranquillamente
no lo sciamano lo sciamano sicuro
sciamano basta ho deciso ma mia mamma mi
defilo maresca ai compagni e fa male e
cosa sta succedendo e che dovete sapere
che adesso non ci rivediamo quando ti
rivedi poi dici ok processo esagerando
invece non rivedendo di perché ci sono
la schermata di giornale sfugge tutto di
mano ragazzo va bene cosa che lo
sciamano perché io non ho ancora lo sai
che calcia ma io non sto giocando
perché hai scelto e che cosa non lo so
che ti spieghiamo allora questo che
vedete qua in basso dell'eroe e a 15
punti vita questo è il nemico e ne ha
dieci locali è il primo spiega perché
sono pensano che tutti abbiano 10 e poi
lo prendiamo gli bauci cinema uccisi
questa è una 10 il prossimo ne ha di più
però vabbè
il primo è facile noi deve facilissimo
avere l'obiettivo è portarlo a 0 e tu
per far per portarlo a 0 evochi mostri e
attacchi con le magie e sava infelici e
tre da anni questo qua non può essere
abbassata di magia potrero è devastante
e non possono attaccare subito quando li
carichi che ha meno carabina carica non
può essere persone maggior potere e
passiamo vediamo che fa
vediamo se facessimo nell'interrogazione
diverso lui avvocato 1 con carica quindi
lui può attaccare subito serapio neka
franzi di come perdere subito da sempre
evocatore di totem allora io direi
questo qua questo cerchio quale il
potere eroe sarebbe una carta fissa che
c'è ogni round e ogni eroe c'è un potere
lo è diverso giustamente si lui cosa che
c'è a lui questo da due ratti 11 ammazza
o comunque pescato quello che ti
risolverebbe la partita questo però noi
vogliamo dare più aggressivi quando vuoi
fare perché volendo potreste anche
tirargli su due danni in faccia passi
massi ha proprio così massima sì ma io
ci credo ok io ci credo sia invece
abbiamo bene o no che stupido che questo
che ha silenziato la noc e stupido non è
capace dice 3 danni però non ce l'ho
allora in questo momento è più no quando
ciò che la carta non sovraccarico in
questo punto io farei così
dopo questo al di là di la di là di
lacca perché sa già significa per il
milan
dall'altra quello che esce dalle uova ed
epica cina è torinese vigile di re
immagina questo voglio allora il fatto
che se mi attacca lui anche i suoi 15 di
trevi 7 maglia viola non moriamo moriamo
moriamo però non è detto neanche tu
vinca adesso però
tempestini io direi che ce li leviamo di
tra i quali rimborsiamo nel ca pranzi e
poterlo è così sono prenditori dovremmo
aver vinto poi ragazzi giorno dopo
abbiamo vinto a chi questo no non puoi
praga questo è il primo dobbiamo battere
i 10
la particolarità dello sciamano e che
utilizza le carte con sovraccarico
sovraccarico diciamo che è un malus tra
virgolette che ti blocca i cristalli di
mano per il livello successivo il turno
successivo ha già è vero che non posso
infatti in questo tool e non lo puoi
fare però è pescato una spada casa solo
due però sfiga ora siamo veramente
ma io lo farei comunque sovraccarico
appunto a carico 1 il turno dopo puoi
giocare con quella elementare elementi
come sicuro di c2 ma io rischierei ai
lavori la gente quando c'è lei tallinn
mano allora ascoltiamo stefano è infatti
fatto bene perché secondo me
la prendevamo dentro raga ma la prima
era scontata il primo round l'abbiamo
vinto ho finito le carte non servono
si no ma perché finto le carte che
questo praticamente in questa modalità
avventura il mazzo si compone piano
piano battendo i boss ei colori non
l'avevo già più
ma facciamo delle scelte che sono
finestre anzi la prima strage era per
far capire che la prima avevo detto che
la prima la semplice praga o una busta
c'è la busta sai cosa non ho pensato non
è che la verità il gioco troppo alto
leggiamo teoria non dovrebbe ragazza
attività per favorire gioco contro parma
gara abbiamo spiato tutto sotto icone
per olio naturale
no così fatto a san e andare aprire
pensavo avessi messo il dato dei vado
mai controlla l'audio a primapress vai
vai a prima sono cinque le leggendarie
sono dura 1 stefano una leggendaria una
leggendaria stand by ma quali niente
maledizione perché non trova perché
quando siamo sul mio computer le
leggendarie non si trovano e quando
siamo sul tuo non lo so sinceramente
erano cup vuol dire po casuale oppure
altresì potenza giovanni un segreto
quindi volta che giochi un segreto il
nome piero è una nuova funzione di
questa espansione e buchi più lupi
oppure sia vostre lupi se c'è chi un
segreto con quella buchi tra il look se
giochi due segreti né we have a ben
quattro fico non ho sbagliato da dare è
che mi vedono tutti e di tutti i mazzi
di genere allora perché basta cliccare
li leggenda se non ci credevo manco io
fallo vedere però vabbè ma non gioco in
classificata da un po ma dove mi
chiamano le 70 un poco la stagione
quindi non è ovvio sono gallina ed ora
anche più falso vai tu dai vado io
ma vuol dire mi tiene la psicosi si no
perché stanno valorizzate
dobbiamo scegliere la prima abilità
negativa nei confronti dell'avversario
quindi a inizio aprile pesca le carte
quindi no non è negativa e carina ti
senti per l'avversario perché nel senso
che positiva per noi questo è uomo molto
buona
il debito era ciclo primario scrittori
hanno un più 1 più 1 ma io direi
il tuo servizio anno più uno più o la
prima o la seconda questa interessante
vuol dire che tipo il totem che arriva a
14 in casa e dai fare la bandiera
catturata potenziamento bandiera
catturata e adesso dobbiamo scegliere
sicuro più cray murlo che sono iva in
faccia che non abbiamo però gli
elementari ha pensato bene pensaci bene
secondo faccio quello che vuoi tu
secondo me in modo che sono più ammazzo
agro quindi io prenderei dai vai murlo
dai ricordati che vai avanti servirà di
giocarsela a lungo termine
chi vuole muro questo quindi ci divida
prossimo ti avevo detto che la rivolta e
noi lo batteremo e noi lo abbatteremo
bellusci non è tantissimo non è neanche
tanto monitor non posso va bene è una
questione di vita o di morte che va bene
al fato tra tu e tu hai scelto la strada
dei murdoch non la condivido tutto però
ti accompagnerà in questa brutta
avventura
va bene anche se non la condivido quindi
vediamo cosa rischiamo già il totem è
buono considerando più delle carte che
abbiamo in mano guadagneranno esatto
anche il mazzo ovviamente più uno più
note fi ma anche il totem è certo
noventa potè il totem quello là non so
ai lati di confronto so dire proprio
federer o esce il totem 11 cioè tu
guarda che cosa faccio adesso
c'è questo è meno evoca un altro 22
scherzando allora sì allora contate ma
si sia ovviamente se ragazzi il nostro
avversario che conviene distruggere il
prima possibile in teoria porca troppo
allora fallo fallo sul 32 così non lo
perdi potenzia lui bravo sì sì sì
gli attacchi quell'aggeggio schifoso
perché poi fa un danno a tutti molto
bene
non puoi pensare di lei così ha subito
mamma mia realtà 3x4 12 ragazzi il mondo
boss abbiamo già vinto quarto round ciao
ciao belli non era prevista questa cosa
se ne frega
così si chiama pm di comiziano bad
manners maniere
la superstar o cattive maniere perché
vuol dire che non solo li hai creato in
faccia ma è fatta anche pesare ucciderti
cosi petrucci del chianche così è anche
cosa noi siamo forti
non ci sono più bullock però come mai
allora questa no
occhio che la prima è tanta roba metti
sul campo sui tre casuale della mano di
un giocatore è fortissimo e
chiaroveggente facevo da questa questa
kier
anche qui non è male da prima la prima è
il aprirebbe avere diciamo rush spalle
così vai vai a prima kajer merce dai
pelo gelido che ha servito eventi di
vita a 20 di vita pensavo di poter e dai
ragazzi saranno sempre di più è il segno
canale non ce l'aspettavamo
ti ricordi quello li raddoppiamo i punti
vi oppure facciamo un'altra cosa a casa
facciamo altra cosa a caso uno contro
uno 70 di vita cosa stanno ascoltando se
no guarda che più tardi è fatto subito
che rallentiamo quelle cacao
assolutamente quelle con il pallino
argentata riteniamo si la spada vorrebbe
fare tanto e fortissima cioè le spade
funzionano tutte le armi quello che
vedete a destra la durabilità della
spada mini può attaccare tre volte
quella sinistra invece
il colpo che c'è quanto fa male la
scalata spada non prendere più
no non è solimini meno male bene legale
non può essere passarli maggior potere
raggiungere un servitore appena letto
però ed è 3 2
il legale abbiamo già vinto questa
ragazzi schifo non mi piace mangiare la
coda del gambero sa proprio di di coda
di gambero sa di buccia
cosa vuoi fare siamo alla pulce proviamo
con il totem station che si esce
potenziato ma mai tanto non puoi non
puoi sfruttare da altre carte o le pure
va beh una cosa ragazzino mano è
buonissimo 6 perché il 2 che ha forti
pronti andata bene che c'è anche questo
buon squama andata bene se dai da c'è un
urlo un altro totem ma io sì direi
[ __ ] il potenziamento di quello
buttano così il prossimo turno ai
difensori di armi sono certo qua bisogna
giocare aggressivi primi round poi più
avanti ma la moglie lui perde il suo
cavalca lupi conta un po se metti
qualcosa nel mezzo a succede se furto
vitale che dovresti riguadagnare life
points e di qualcosa al centro
non vorrei che farla però siamo più di
lì che di la fa niente se pero che
l'immagine di un uomo che la sparati
addosso [ __ ] puoi farlo sì lo sapevo
ci sono dei video su internet a volte
gente che stava spara addosso si spara
la palla è un must da dieci non fa bene
il primo file mi split siamo a tre
ragazzi è più veloce la luce invece la
faccia feroce
allora l'acqua solo una carta una carta
che però è una carta che non è presente
nelle carte comuni di hairston la cart
extra adatto territorio di potere futuro
di bosco che questa edizione super furia
del vento va bene perché a carte finché
la tua mano non è piena
costa 1 e devastante anche super furia
del vento schifo non fare super frey
event può intaccare 4 euro
solo uno di costituzione un boom solo
uno e attacco scusami quindi levi
quattro progetti si rompe perché è
targato sì esatto
io bordi l'assenza psi for fondo ma sì
perché ti salva in alcune veramente sta
carta non esiste bourlot puntare tutto
sul muro controlla non ci siano carte
più fuori questo e molto no involuzione
sì per opel
ci potrebbe regalare tante gioie
soprattutto maleficio più avanti
importante per riascoltarmi il pesce
livorno ho capito allora che carini come
fece vincere con h dove eccolo muro e
cacciamo a reggere o 33 cacciatore ha
neanche usare normalmente riccardo
mazzoni bottini che gli ultimi 70 30 di
vita ma però anche la nostra vita sale
di spiega meglio se no magari persone
sempre su osvaldo
lo sapevo 30 noi 30 gli altri più avanti
saranno un po diversi vediamo
craxi torino io perché c'è maleficio si
chiama non l'hai preso forse la vita un
ok per 76 ne va tutto male cioè tieni
tutto tranne maleficio scusa vai alla
voce maleficent ricordi uno solo però
fino a certi secondo ci avrebbe fatto
comodo e sul campo a bad run che ne
siamo un mazzo alghero non ci abbiamo
bisogno di quello ma quella lì è
pericolosa meno che tu non abbia cult
usati ma non farlo
questo mette sul campo un servizio caso
della madonna ogni giocatore ha molte
infatti non è qui hai avuto luogo a meno
che io non abbia che tusa di mare si fa
per voi che molti tifosi butti lui o lui
un grosso ha però un danno a tutti i
servitori interessante è utile in questo
momento e salvati più ciccioni altri sì
prossimo turno chi l'aveva due mostri
fatto male quanto male fa somazzo
incredibile
è la fortuna però un rebus a versare un
altro round dove te lo salvi squadra è
già vinta
giannini e se non peschi un mostro
solo dopo ti consiglio di fare richiamo
ancestrale cairo è forte come la metti
naval murlo pesche uno sparo da tre e ce
la portiamo a casa dai no scherzavo sei
vivo boom che famo scontà avanti da anni
sono gli altri tre in man non bastano
spera che non esca
potrebbe esserci rovescio della medaglia
è vincere o vincere non proprio deve
distruggere tutti quanti non so come 13
ciao che conta ben e conta conta conta
bastano non bastano non è vero ne sarei
stato feste bastano basta allora perché
questo al bar che culo non bastavano sul
serio le fiere di milan avevo mai fatto
conto di quello è comunque una
passeggiata ma nessuno ha capito una
mazza di prestazione che abbiamo fatto
però abbiamo avuto culo se gesù cade a
questo gioco poi iniziata conosce
veramente tutte quante le carte
a quel punto saprete tutti i meccanismi
meglio che prendiamo abbiamo ebbene no
amenta c quello al centro durature
antiche dove la gente pensa cosa fa
strano scusa morte tra sociali tenenza
di tricase in costando in più è forte è
forte
tra l'altro che si fa c'era anche
l'altra volta no ma a 40 di vita più un
opprimente servitore ai a noi ce
l'abbiamo di base quindi è anche lui ma
lui deve cliccarci sopra e pagare 2 è
vero intendo emessa da vantaggiato
nostri lasciamo amici sul giornale sul
mio nodo marini a casa mia chiamo tutto
al pomeriggio non aiuta e manco cinque
pacchetti fungo man the floor è un tuo
amico murlo cosa sei
ma io sono bello
c'è il fortissimo dato lui non tossisce
cosa faccia è non lo so spinge via io
leverei anche cota si chiamano lavoro
lavoro rischiamo quello che epoca
sicuramente ci metto quello che vuoi dai
due tra tutti e due ma veramente mai
tranquillo è una passeggiata tiene pure
scritto niente rai abbiamo perso
non è vero non è pessimista ma l'ha
definita una delizia almeno anche lui lo
ha pescato niente questo dai dai dai 22
io col tempo farei più possibile pali in
campo cioè tanti mostri così poi abbiamo
la possibilità di fare tra le come si
deve come un tempo e dopo metto
difensori argus primi freddi minicleri
perde una miseria questo mette tanti
mostri e poli prudenza
la famiglia vabbè pazienza vai fuori
vado io a questo qua e lo leviamo
mettiamo il murdoch e lo potenziamo bene
questo ci si vuol dire quando
attacchiamo se fa 3 danni riprendiamo 3
di vita che va bene ma adesso no
purtroppo vedo così secondo me non siamo
messi malissimo adesso magari si
schianta il murlo sceglie devo punto
temi di bach
se non mi toglie i nostri nomi li ha
tolti non è vero mai 6 felissimo allora
se me li trasforma semini trasforma
possono attaccare subito fai dei conti
prima tu devi pulirgli il campo prima
che potenzi tutto quindi io sì direi
vada io farei così li pulisco il campo e
poi li trasformò che di sicuro insieme
come fai ti muoiono alcuni io farei la
spada ivan ora nessuno lui gli leva lui
ok questo e poi lui rileva lui e voleva
lui no no perché lui a perdere attacco
con tanti uno più 22 guarda uno per
dell'attacco lo è stato recuperato
brevità 22 e quindi poi prima di tutto 3
è per solo tre mossi sei sicuro che
quello che stai facendo o due tra al pro
lo so ma se metti altri mostri tour dopo
sanno ancora di più ma perché
facciamo mai dire che il totem e 1
quelli sono due
baggio particolare su questo sono tutti
potenziati però poteva andare molto
peggio dicono sicuri o finto e sushi o
copiatura se n'è andata
quando muoiono evocano dei fatto in di
base è forte si inizia tutti qua
beh a su punto ti direi veramente forte
io comunque pulire il campo
no io vado in faccia ad ora basta anche
l'argus a sto punto è anche una potenza
di due attacco ma stiamo veramente
domandi la sinistra penso male sti
36enne quindi sui 21 da anni in un tale
teoria colo dopo se non me li tocca
dovrei aver vinto e ora sicuramente
potenzia tutto un team di base però non
può attaccare con le famiglie
ciao sono resi quell'ora per questo
sparagli anche i tre dagli in faccia che
ti vogliamo
i ragazzi anche la quinta sfida e andare
ne mancano 4
mancano quattro partite ma la prossima
sarà quella meno e per diverse sul mio
canale davvero non siamo mai andati
oltre la setta assicurati chiede del
doppio alla tua vita il tuo potere è più
potente costa 126 vittoria ancora le tre
carte atina due volte proprio grido di
battaglia anche questa allora
considerando le carte che hai
sono fortissimi tutti e tre perché hai
un botto di battaglia per tenere che
guasta e più potente costa uno pensa
però al totem il primo che quando ha
avuto il murdoch che ne mette 30 set
e quindi poi come potenziali
trasformandoli tutti insieme bello se
anche anche avere tutti più due più due
tikriti di battaglia abbiamo un bel po
12 no se già 234 cioè usa di ritrarla di
22 va assolutamente il primo set è
sovraccarico che prendiamo qua non mi
piace sfida
beh non c'è una domanda e per questo ha
racc
ma ragnaros the comeback of the king ma
non ci voleva di battaglia quello fa 10
danni ma piaci da anni sto coso via sta
roba non pensarci neanche un secondo in
più secondo vai vai tra st mi va bene da
grazie stavolta faccio il prossimo al
sicuro 50 di vita
però noi non siamo messi noi abbiamo
forato laguna russo lui è la divinità
scesa in terra è stato pure bannato al
formato è vero però preparazione cibo
dei mezzo sì sì e proveniente mangiano
anche se mi nero
no non capisco cosa si capisce di mamma
vado a caccia mare 2 ok no no no no no
no no no no no no no no spazio ci sei
non abbiamo due film firmati va
benissimo questa mano è perfetta
abbiamo già vinto sono no ti ricordo che
cosa fa il tuo che dei battesimi ho
capito non tra 5 banale per dire che al
sesto turno abbiamo vinto ci metto la
mano sul fuoco
ok va bene c'è un aspetto 50 vivida 77
con l'aiuto voleva tra la vari tolto
tutta la vita butta il tuo cammino
iniziamo a riempire sto bordo 2.1
madonna
ma secondo turno sta roba è una roba
indecente quanto perché lui sa quanto
cristallina
mantova però anche lui l'ha fatto in
passato i fulmini
no direi lui sa più dove l'accesso è già
un culetto io allora uno io lo faccia di
farli fuori tutti e due
sei sicuro di cui mi aspetterei tanto
try to come non è io il 23 o mi attacca
lui per farlo anche dopo stavo pensando
che non hai la carta per il turno dopo
non hai la carta costo 4 di mana penso
poi che totò riina non lo so mi lascia
attaccare tanto se lui mi di latta ok
l'avvocato l'album entourage non mi
attaccherà ovviamente ok è scemo sta
andando bene cosa faccio cadere
trasforma sia inserito il casuale in
costa 3 in più su chi lo fa su di lui
maggio madonna volta roma ciani va bene
segui la tempesta beh può subito potere
fare
quello che cura ok allora le varie dagli
albori scegli i tuoi arboscelli la
borselli e passa in teoria se menetto
qualsiasi cosa toglie va bene va bene va
bene non a cristalli di male quello va
bene va bene va bene un baby e di dire
io è l'ospite stata ragioniamoci questo
no no però è vocazione tempo
assolutamente mai senza dubbio a lui
torneranno tutti i cristalli però la
partita è finita
se la partita e parliamo di unità perché
poi il mondo come potrai dovrebbe più 44
livelli sopra vuol dire che questi
escono cinque turisti senza 5 tutti
circa ct da un'ora che spiega che
trasforma kajer né cosa che hai
no ce ne sopra carico non abbiamo tenuto
conto meglio così come meglio che tu
devi pulire il campo assolutamente quei
quattro danni facili sul 6 5 e schianta
c 13
tira fuori un punto temi non sbrando
cascata auto aspetta
diretta non abbiamo tenuto conto che
chiede il sovraccarico scritta dai ci
abbiamo pensato però ti ricordo che il
turno dopo ai sei elisir settimana e
questo fa 6 da anni quindi gli uccelli
uno di questi due cosi in un colpo solo
sempre se non facciamo tabelle
le direi che potremo tra l'altro però
c'è un botto di roba in campo ben due
frase va bene allora io io giocherei più
safe poi tu fai la scelta che preferisci
io giocherei quello che fa 6 daniele re
il 66
come faccio a proprio sinceramente farei
così quello là sopra il 13 su 21 o
schifoso via quei due facciate
si schiantarono secondo me può anche
pura teoria sì boh non lo so che stai
veramente difficile
ok in faccia per me va benissimo 76 77
quel tizio madonna
bene niente dai tra alfano come aspetta
però se vuoi fare tra altri così ai
attaccare prima perché perché poi non
posso trascurare no sei sicuro al mille
per cento
certo 22 allora metto anche road totem
mi trasformo anche quello etero
trasformi o preferisci potenziare quelli
che arrivano dopo perché non ti serve
adesso della così tanto uno in più che
lui trasforma metti il totem attacca con
pronto lo metti tu questo mai detto che
non mi serve adesso dopo la
trasformazione
noi ti consiglio di rai 2 1 1
sì ci stiamo il live anche ci ho capito
il tuo ragionamento adesso sì allora
facciamo si parla 54 sgombra nilo e poi
ci divertiamo
vediamo che succede poi magari non
funzionano a quattro livelli in più bene
beh noi siamo messi male poteva andare
meglio andar meglio
e comunque il controllo totale non fa
niente questa calda che è molto malata
sociale di quanti ne votanti tutto
questo a 10 da anni ragazzi in giocato
un elementare del punto nel turno
precedente non a 10 da anni ragazzi vuoi
farlo sul no è no allora ammazza quei
tre cosi tutti e tre il tuo potere
adesso un altro leggi lo hanno visto il
trattamento sanitario una chiusura
crostoni punto all'altro e che tre io
che è successo è sentito rumore di
chitarra fortitudo allora vuoi
trasformarne sede no no non piccole vuoi
io farei il totem del fuoco nelle
mentale o in toto hanno ingiustamente io
pinge lo farei
non ti piace perché perché lo fai tutte
e tre le cose
tu hai la fa è l'evoluzione due file
traldi ma cosa fa quello devastante
io aspetterei io farei pin già e totem
quanto cosa può far l'alterazione quello
che vuoi
cosa può farti niente abbiamo
praticamente fuori strada in faccia pure
lavoro ma c'è il totem ok altro di morte
trasformi quello strato il tanto ben
poco male ma è un buon town tra l'altro
non pesca finché non è piena
quando scarti la carta mescolavano
davanti non ci interessa va bene la
partita e di tutto bene
io il settimo glie lo lascerei no che te
frega io perché rei a farei borsa per
cercare un elementale laici danni attori
avevamo ragazzo 81 cost noi peschiamo
l'apecar tensione 23 la donna lo
metterei subito nati nella sua mente io
ma anche sempre scaffali film e volevo
volevo volevo ricreare che cosa fai
douglas ometti elementare dove c'è 10
danni gratuiti ma per chi ragiona non
hai prestato a vinta questa proviamo
metteremo tral vuoi fare il nuovo
stralcio che cosa succede ai verdi per
formare ge ha la pecca non è messo anche
elementale prima testa pignolo
questo siciliano ma aspetta questo più
forte puntiamo revoca elementale cioè i
10 da anni almeno il turno dopo ma
abbiamo vinto stanco me ne frega
questa da 12 un po più salire perché
perché il massimo quello no se esiste
anche uno d'acqua esistono da fattore
mai farlo e noi sono mi trova niente
ora ci ritroviamo cosa al testing
no niente il massimo era 12 detto non mi
ascolti e non per provare die for fun
skipper anni valentia
avremmo già vinto lo sai massima era per
provare adesso perdiamo io spero siano o
no
fa troppo terreno però ci stava dai sì
che dice di fuoco che purifichi mi ero
dimenticato conclude oppure andiamo
avanti ragazza poteva il suo mazzo
possiamo averlo normalmente purtroppo
bellissimo ora una pausa spacchetta
mente un'altra bustina aspetta prima
vediamo
morlock siamo altri due che altro
sarebbe sappiamo vigore
ti prego ti prego ti prego di fare
un'accurata una epica e vabbè ho capito
ma che nel sotto canestro e non solo
leggendario io sono happy era meglio non
parte 56 di bustine pure figo non è male
ma 9 costa la madonna e murray così un
drago parecchio tasto acer e credo che
lo mette in mano cosa vuol dire cose che
non si doveva per forza costa 9 non era
né avanti questo caldo può creare dei
servitori di cera 60 di vita e la
penultima ma mancano solo due parti non
mancando per aria se sicuro no facendo
anche entre è sicurissimo
abbiamo sarebbe stata una banca trail
mancano due metti la cera togli la cera
visto che lui c'era il gioco di rena
costa 3 esiste la parola ce romantici e
roma te
vabbè se non esiste il primo è
fortissimo sono curiosissimo di vedere
una cella dietro mamma mia che va bene
quanto forte che non amano piena abbiamo
presente come far subito no no no l 1
dopo e romantica il tar futuro la faccia
elementale corso al terzo leggi sul
potere il piacere evoca la proprio un
servitore di cera non so chi sia e
attrezzi la vera 33 non so allora
attaccano subito perché secondo me
danni a tutti io no in mano e questo
fenomeno ha messo in mano bella usi il
terzo turno mai metti il malo che va al
cuore va tanto molto quella aperta anche
sulla usi subito ce l'hai con riserva
per il futuro
ne ho fame ancora qualcosa in cucina
notte poi perdiamo perdiamo dai perché
non ci pensare poi un muro che
sacrifichi purtroppo fondamento
contrastarli più le carte ma scusami poi
facesse per il suo segreto che verso
sera sto segreto perché un grant e è sì
perché verde quando in rosa ma quando
giallo paladino chiedere scusa però
c'era verde quando l'ha messo segreto io
quello lì lo farei fuori con argus
potenzierei uno dei totem con argus ma è
indifferente per fare anche top ten
totem e scegliete argus d'oro letto con
argus non perdi un bus a sapere che a
volte ci dimentichiamo di quanto
porporine di potere che danno cielo
secondo me dimentica ce la stavamo già
portava a casa la casa va bene è tanto
di grafici io ti direi bo.fi il totem
doppio forum quello mettilo e il
celebret come totem a due totem diversi
magari quello town
il vostro tizio si perché tanto sicuri
ma guarda che mi fa il danno a lui e che
sta attaccando guarda
no perché per molti sarebbe stato
ridicolo il dio lo treviolo figuriamoci
un pochino appena un anno fa per un
servizio
c'era una copia dei nostri seguito a dei
nostri servitori ciao che sì sì ambarabà
ciccì coccò cava l'ora che il como e ti
spacco il culo bene ti spacco il culo
perché peccato era ignorando se non lo
devo anche a lui se no sarebbe troppo
tutto in faccia una volta che cosa
faccio chiamo da pescare no no no no eh
beh però poi c'è la mano pieno e penserà
una carta non ne vale la pena
la dovremo usare prima o poi 32 sullo 0
3 questa partita è già finita
e giusto fare 3 2 sul 30 0 e 9 3 2 su 6
guadagnano mi devo il più scarso ma
perché devi prenderti tutti quei danni
in faccia non ha senso ma scusa se lei
lo zero stili qui così perdono attacco
ha già capito non diventano però c'è tv
quello lì lo potresti anche schiantare
ma non lo portava lo stesso i suoi
mostri va bene leva uno meno ritorno
levava qui due quando non mi dava
qualsiasi cosa anche questo mi lavoro
fatto ma come mondo di attaccare come
con cosa non mi volevano più buttate
meno tanto telo cura di uno
e intanto ti becco giallo 83 li faccia
di uno di aver lasciato quindi poter
nemmeno dimenticato le foto di ragnolo
strettamente tanta roba che però non so
se troppo copiare e lo so come va bene
adesso il collare bechara glarus
colpisce la rai la nostra non uccidere
non vincerà attenzione non lo so dai il
controllo totale della partita ora ti
faccio vinto non ho vinto io leverei
quel coso carriera anni giusto noi lo
leviamo andiamo diretto nei locali
bayern insicuro
ma alla c'è una legge mai
ma vige un try ardone raillard doni
vediamo cosa rischiamo involuzione
perché un pescara meglio questo che con
il temibile siamo un altro no niente la
wii play back è vero pensa a quanti
volevano di nuovo se lo colpisce però
vuol dire la sfida di nidi conta quanti
sono i danni
non bastano perché raniero sono un po da
51 conta i danni non bastano
adesso stai per fare una magia i danni
basteranno magicamente a è vero c'è cosa
che aveva già conta è solo sia allora sì
ce la facciamo
questo fa sei gravi danni 6 11 si già
facciamo che non avevo visto diciamo
questo os enti o vuoi pescari cento arte
manco le guardi o no
[Musica]
abbiamo vinto la sfida d'avventura hai
visto
ma quello altra sera nerd ma ora che
sono 77 i boss sconfitti ma sappiamo
contare a punto una kahuna sono otto non
10 8
allora si era ragione ragazzi l'ultima
l'ultima sfida è tra l'ultima carta
all'ultima carta cascate che avevano
piena no ma che ci sarà un servizio di
sanitari nella tua mano diventano due
corpi e leggine man e godin quello che
fa pesca tre carte costano zerba non
prevedo già no si no a me piace anche
questo ma il primo è però mai prendi
muro l'abbiamo preso murlo camera
chiudiamo comunità nell'ultima saga the
last match 70 di vita a re coreco
barrique ubaldo ricco baldo parte il
sera a carico dei voti trova un tesoro
che soldi retro con tesoro fratello vuol
dire the last match for the avengers
anche in inglese e schiere si può le
schede
si pensa degli armeni siamo sempre bene
non è capire quale ero è un attribuiva
questo aggeggio la tempesta volte buona
mano ecco valdo spera che non sia un
ricco vagone no che il fork avati
peschiamo la carta che ha quattro ce
l'ho fatta dal canale grande carta che
ha fatto quello che costa 4 il fucile
maligno non ebbe anche noi abbiamo 50 di
vita lungo le struggere rendere tutela è
che già ora fuoco elementare può darsi
eccoci perché atlete perché basta nella
madonna no veloce l'abbiamo fatto non
subito raga l'ultima partita di
schiavoni perla è fortissimo l'ultimo
nome ne parliamo la russia me ne vado ve
lo giuro capisce perché dobbiamo rimarrà
perché magari non lo sanno se la
perdiamo ora che dobbiamo iniziare da
capo
noi lo abbiamo detto no perché non
lavano pescara gas e perdiamo l'ultima
dobbiamo iniziare daccapo matto ecco che
non vogliamo rifare capitolo ce la
possiamo fare
vai buono metti il difensore che tanto è
vero che non gli avevano detto che se
perdiamo da riparare ma non dobbiamo
perdere la casa dobbiamo iniziare tutto
da zero
se il prossimo turno quei due murlo che
sono vivi facciamo il casino totale ma
li abbiamo due volte perché abbiamo il
doppio grido di battaglia con lui buono
non può attaccare con i genitori
anche qui in digitale veleno basta
veleno pasta veleno che non c'è mai lo
troviamo butta lì
intanto direi più tirata luco peuterey
salute furtività provocazione che cazzo
ci fregano
pensavo mi chiama 15 allora ci come
detenere involuzione sì la facciamo il
turno dopo tanto qualcosa non può
attaccare così via meno dove vanno
invece porca vacca va bene va bene a
meno che non abbia una carta che
distrugge tutti mousse cosa ma questo è
scemo
un record ma se basta
si no ma poi scusami silenzio è visto
che cosa serve silenziare i soli
distruggi primo secondo me non sa ma
questo è scemo no vera gara sempre come
ma scusami ma non è possibile
vabbè quindi visto che ha una carta così
ogni volta navazio scemi non so come
possiamo fare a vincere sta partita
adesso però io ora involuzione la farei
perché se noi facciamo mai danno io
inizierei a fargli danno
ciao levarglielo cui è colui che mi
raccomando perché perché
il segreto non abbiamo visto cos'era ma
è questo che eccolo eccolo li ringrazio
questo è un mio difetto si distruggevano
l'altro s ma loro no
raga ma stiamo scherzando
ogni servitore scegli un lato del campo
casuale mi pare che tutti abbiamo
chiedere a mare troverò raccomandato
nora che non solo modo che vince una ma
non possiamo più di c'e un solo modo
dalla tempesta
intanto porca [ __ ] the coast a zero ha
tempestato in festa la tempesta che
merda
nola vuol dire sì alla buonissimo
purissimo buonissimo serata non sono
scarse ma la tempesta deve iniziare alle
varie questi due sono quelli che deve
avere uno per volta
poi buttiamo tutto qua si faccia per
ricci morire faceva cioè che li pulisce
il campovolo e sei li dava iniziamo con
questi modelli sono copia
a sinistra sinistra sinistra suisse caio
smettete quello sinistra sinistra qua si
perché questo l'ho avuta ad essa auto
l'aria non veramente questa difficile
pensa se adesso fa un altro treno
c'erano ma questa è ingestibile si può
pure che però costa tutto il male che ha
quindi adesso siamo tranquilli ultim'ora
grande sì alla fine di ogni turno evo
che servitori morti durante quel tour
non si è sicuri vuole giocare ai nas
però aspetta questo conti col giallo
quando cioè di trade da poter fare che
21 si rievoca tutto quanto si giocherà
gran perché è che dopo giochiamo l'altra
capito quindi li butto giù tutto quello
che si spaventa che possano rendendolo
sì no no che poi rischia molecola lascia
di una fede di becca lui poi davvero
attacca la lascio la palla ma se
vogliamo utilizzare i danni cpu volevo
puntare anche ai 13 faccia magari semi
vedere la carta che ci spodesterà la
vita attenzione contro solo tre di mano
tra l'altro che abbiamo intorno
abbiamo vinto lorenzo fidati stata enel
bouches tutto 10 e regala a emilio leva
il campo con i 221 senza 10 stermini
a sterminio uno sterminio perdi n'è uno
no no con un seguito all'attacco nero
letta che invece un territorio adiacente
5 e sono altri otto bello mio pagatore
no non parlo perché tanto quando parlo
io va beh lasciamo l'unica carta a
pattinare quella di firma che cambia
cambia tutto in campo e abbiamo perso ma
abbiamo vinto abbiamo perso si mette
quella che cambia tutto in campo e va
bene ti direi
direi che è tuffato a prescindere e
anche ovviamente il totem possiamo
vincere ancora non frenerà possiamo
vincere davvero a fine turno tra acceso
rendere la stupenda dalle camere di ogni
turno ok quindi se lui muore torna
nathan
insomma quando lei la depressione ma
domina tutto morilla ufficio catalane
libica ma no no è chiaro quante caro
stiamo a perdere l'ultimo raga non
possiamo perdere all'ultimo ma non
possiamo perdere all'ultima partita dai
non thounds dai quattro si può fare buon
hockey spara no prima tempesta i tuoi
servitori morti la tempesta boom tuorli
tuona subito lì
quando giocate non sovraccarico potevo
mettere questo e poi l'altra sono qui
pensavo il controllo del gioco ma lo
show man mano per ogni carta usata miss
play
mi spiace se perdiamo per uno perché se
per gli après nous me ne vado ma perché
bastare la cima meglio congelati che
morti tra l'altro questo qua quindi ha
creato una carta stupida della cia la
podistica prima ma insomma di figlio
congelati che morti negli orecchi che i
morti purtroppo non serve a niente
tira ma io ci credo cioè non può avere
un'altra di quelle detti strugge tutto
sarebbe una cosa sbagliata
no infatti manca il vocabolario degli
eteri coltrane e unico casuale va bene
il mito di questa sera questo turno a
faccia dopo gaza sta cosa mi spaventa e
book assetti robot si può bene sa caro
combattere colore nero spero che non ho
me l'ha tolto uno ha tolto la foto o se
abbiamo vinto ha vinto non abbia vinto
ovviamente non avevano ragione vero
allora un fermo no non ero con brando si
attacca al primo cenno 3
18 di arma va bene va bene la mia vasca
allora e adesso la situazione è
veramente di me ovviamente di attaccare
tutto facile robot bombe venti le fa
esplodere lui è comunque consapevole
metti un altro totem sperando che riesca
perlomeno cura tutto in faccia e un
regalo ora dai coloma 2
speriamo che ci seccatura ciao amici è
stato bellissimo stare con voi
boom tre missili 13 e la nostra gaia
iaia che il buzz e tranquilli tranquilli
adesso rischiamo la carta che ci fa per
scaricare tutte le gare come che si
chiama la top back grazie perdiamo qua a
10 di vita perdiamo air iniziamo tutto
da zero perché la 10 di vita non
riusciamo a toglierli 10 solo 10
io credo che siamo così possiamo vincere
solo con quella carta da che ci fa
scriveva fiscale tutte le carte
seguici la carta tavano come salito del
leggendario abbia tanto dai divertire i
nostri dorato vabbè non c'è più spazio
io farei di tutto ma tira il murdoch e
ovviamente questo qua così sì no no no
no ora il totem e poi fai trovano qui
l'unica è sperare che esca qualcosa di
molto forte
tanto in provocazione power a più 4 più
qua dai va bene dai sindaci fa vincere
la partita
non ne sono ci fa vincere la partita
questo cosa fa la ragazza attirando come
degli schifosi
no no no non sia uno basta raja non è
vero è la partita più sobri non ho mai
sofferto che dittatura reddito anni che
gioco scorretto dai ma perché est e
pescate ma che schifo non ha veramente
senso chi fi libera fin c'erano lui lui
lui proprio attacco se vai vai qualcosa
che devasti tutto quanto grazie 45 56
dai ninja possono sognare di attaccare
come viviamo quelli non spieghi tempo
inizia come una scissione
si chiama the night siano l'abbiamo già
usata involuzione maledizione l'unica è
un maleficio
ora il totem totem un certo tema già
cazzo sono servitori in uno che in più
in là della apple nonostante aspettati
già cosa vuoi fare con finta utenza
mattolini da e 24 fa niente alla prima
attacca 88 dopo che ha attaccato si
congela va bene dai
e già qualcosa
e stato allora che è veramente un casino
dopo che ha attaccato si congela se non
riesci a levar me lo faccia per me lo
legherà sicuro e le guide anzi me lo
leva con le magìe nome la donna che
l'unico modo per vincere la partita che
tu peschi è un oracolo elementale questa
mia cittá
elementare ma non può farlo perché non
ha
dovevo carmine vitale e le giocate
nessun elementare ma sicuro intorno
prima nel turno prima adesso non ho
pescato il mar rosso
vai subito buono ogni giocatore pescato
carte dai dai dai quella che pesca o tra
carte attestano settimo due volte
[Musica]
maleficio che recuperiamo allora male
male fisiatra 15 giu ma che glielo fai
subito andando fulmine con me lo terrei
e uno voleva uno a quella scusami dopo
l'annunciata magia spesso si vedeva una
pianta 1 e lanciano come su di essa
se recuperiamo sta partita da vero milan
ma non credo sia possibile andare a
tutti non ci interessa non ci fosse
ancora più partita celebrato di o meno
caspita di bordo aveva quello lì abbiamo
tolto tutto fidati che abbiamo fatto una
rimonta assurda sì dopo dopo dopo allora
aiuto io farei trasforma il 3 1 con il
tuo potere 66 metti lo butto giù e sila
manca andargli diretti e va a fan culo
io leverei il co bullo sodano basta e
l'ebraico boltho butterei il calciatore
pulsa al le opzioni sono due o fai ora
la borsa la borsa e quante carte nel
mazzo conta 33 carafa non fai la borsa
ben 30 abbiamo perso meno male ad ovest
allora ti consiglio di fare ora il
il mega sauro c come ad attaccarlo
diretto dal m lui e ma io non lo so il
mio casaura non glie lo leviamo 22
io abbiamo per tre carte per vincere
dobbiamo andare in faccia basta
ok però lui fece nascere uno se perdi
per quello per questo mega sauro adatta
in urlo che non interessa lui a murlo
l'altro e 6 d'attacco stai scherzando
non puoi fare a ottimizzare le carte che
abbiamo capito se ce li leva queste c'è
la leva subito lui mica ci avrà la
madonna e ma appunto quindi se lei metto
il muro che non cambia niente
non è meglio questo si può raccontare
vicentino dopo per caso dopo solo
madonna che sudata di partita lancia tre
palle che vivevano nella mia musica
suoni
li mortacci sua madre morta nella tomba
il gas e c'era un patrimonio il turno
stesso si prendono due volte qui è vero
che aspetta questa roba perché a persone
di maggior potere fin già però non può
far nulla vari finge potenziarlo però
voglio comunque ti fai però devi farlo
non c'è altra alternativa quando lo devo
aspettare che sperare e pregare che sia
una provocazione provocazione non può
attaccare tra la utilissimi a levargli
il 2 2 ma no prendo danno mi uccido
tutti attacca lui no facciamo che mi
attacchi numeri no se ti attacca lui per
di due ma se glielo levy non ad anni ma
sheen più fai come credi tu alla partita
io sono solito suggerito vedi tu perché
costituita da visita altro finita danni
invece abbiamo perso comunque 53
lei ha perso ancora perso ancora una
pezza solo due ma la provincia solo dove
per vincere non me li la vera dove ha
tolti adesso cominciamo comunque
definito le tante forse aspetta però non
c'è possibilità trasferte che ne sai che
fa perché ne so trasforma intanto il 59
col tuo potere fine ci serve va da sé ma
perché legge cosa fa se stessa in un
robot casuale abbiamo perso lo so no
paga con figli al suo punto chi e 3 15
cosa meno cosa cazzo di facile serve a
niente fare 5 danni r pertanto di
trasformarlo to see some money etica
sono di una carta buona o adesso
se non troviamo niente ci uccidiamo con
la borsa ha però gli ha dato 5 di
armatura un boom boom boom una sega
perché voglio qualcosa che vuol dire mai
quanto a di otto my10 997 10 non si 8 no
fai l'ultima carta elmas
può essere non lo so bene
è stato bello perché noi abbiamo perso
che mai ascoltato questo molto ha fatto
sei danni mette a fare solamente 9
ma i primi molti regioni che dobbiamo
guardare tua madre morta ieri cosa bella
che non riusciremo mai più arrivare
all'ultima separa pure pure la beffa
differente pure per il culo ma lorenzo j
è depresso adesso però capisci quanto
era forte questo qui cioè silenzio e
uccidi tutti mostrino l'avversata tutti
fatti 7 mio dio l'ultimo avevamo vinto
ha vinto pietra questa questa avventura
riuscito a vincere luce ti rendi conto
noi ha vinto pietro cerca un installer
nora che non è possibile
cioè io non ho veramente quello giuro
sono tre fa come ma dai l'ultima voce a
mamma mamma fa 1 contro 1 1 contro mi
viene va a molina e la vera casta
diciamo che si sposta facciamo che basta
avventura visto che sono scarso è
rimasta sei ai dati quanti punti vita
abbiamo tolto dall inizio della partita
tanti mancano sei avevamo vinto niente
cioè io non ho veramente no ma non è
possibile almeno morire all'inizio sai
fai schifo morì subito no alla fine
porca vacca vinto pietro l'ha vinta
pietro l'avventura no è no no comment e
non commentano allora quindi innanzi ce
l'hai ce l'hai pronti mazzi che mazza si
miei ma vai a quelli miei siria step di
marzo ha un pil a standard si la
selvaggia rissa 6 o mista invitando
qualcuno a giocare ma non guardare il
mio in testa già nel 76 77 ammazzo io
uso ammazzo barriera
come faccio scusa non guardiamoci
ragazza va in una situazione cavolata ma
se ti aspetta aspetta devo farli vedere
come siamo messi perché fatto fuori
allora taglio dei mazzi router non
guarderà ai ragazzi anche qui siamo
messi c'è lui che ha girato registrare e
io girerò il mio adesso aspetta
ok non vede me e io non vedo lui la
situazione è veramente ridicola per non
far vedere i mazzi ci giriamo i monitor
va bene se dicessi che mi fa da ostacolo
ok ci siamo
bene dell'universo se fa vj non mi
ricordo neanche il mio mazzo pensate
conquistato tutte le carte che si
giocano la fine della partita bene ora
che c'è il dorso leggendari come che mi
sta aspettando che effettivamente non è
che sono messo genere salute ma sai che
non mi ricordo assolutamente nella vita
non mi ricordo assolutamente il mio
mazzo ceo scelto il mazzo non mi ricordo
un genio
sono curioso adesso questa bellino mai
ma sono stati provocazione che non per
forza ragazzi sono dalla francia sono
franco no veramente cioè non è possibile
allora cos'è quell'aggeggio 35 quanta
gente mi sta aspettando aiuto perché
posso aspettarti più di uno si sa la 3a
non sappiamo alura ad altro e microfono
non so se ti si sente quando parli
perché io non metto in mezzo ma e urlo
york
io farò un miliardo e mezzo di miss play
perché non so giocare più nella vita
però vabbè mi aspetto le tue mosse
non so giocare più nella vita questo
mazzo cioè lo so devo giocare primo
questa è l'espansione prima quello ma
quella prima prima seniori questa sfida
sarà leggendaria felice tra la partita
ma questo non è i massi cosa vi per
andare a leggenda no l'ho copiato
stamattina sta veramente si vabbè allora
questo è uno di separazione
vabbè ma vediamo di fare qualcosa di
carino ed interessante questa cosa fa
quando infligge danni formi fermatura
pari
dobbiamo fare un po di piazza pulita in
giuria lì ma se hai fatto stamattina dai
fatto con l'espansione nuova sì quindi
espansione nuova voce non c'è una le
carte ma se nuova dentro questo mazzo
parte che non ha trovato leggendarie
facciamo così ma contiene rimasto
familia 9156 mese dobbiamo anzi
stefanini scusa mi hai distrutto tutto
finora sc passato quello sarebbe stato
un grosso problema per tutti ci sarà
miss play incredibile per la faccia
sapere la stagione
sa mai beh con turbine non è lo zio otto
spettatori sono tutti quelli della
scorsa live ci scommetto quello che vuoi
almeno mi aspetta nessuno ma perché
allora si aggiungono gli amici a quello
non a quello sopra e stefano badate che
chioma che c'è ma che bella chio mina
che ci a stefanini raga io perdere
questa partita vaticano ii di 7 forse
quello con la questa dovrebbe essere
aggiornato con le carte hanno espansione
secondo me è in sala vigilanza rai
il serraglio e riservato agli ospiti
ovviamente cosa succede quando evoco
quanti il 77 le mosse dei minion con
provocazione quindi con lo scudo che
sono obbligati ad attaccare a lui non
sto pensando che stefano obbligato
attaccare lui prima di attaccare me
diretto vedevo con 7 così gli dà un
potere eroe fortissimo che quello di
ragnaros di prima però arriva a 7 cosa
che non riuscirò mai a fare però a me
grazie stefanino
quando kind ma marco questo castigo
donte fai così sei simpatica rapporto
vendola sta scrivendo penso la scienza
difensore pietà perché non ha giocato
l'altro prima ha giocato questo senso
giocare prima questo no queste cose le
le apprendi giocando tantissimo ex coda
mondo anche i video
se tu girassi di più può vantare solo
senza reali si legge o più parmatour ai
pacchetti sta leggendo i feti nelle
carte visa ero distratto non sentivo già
in mano guardate televisi rai abbiamo un
po
beh ovviamente oggi perdo perdo quali
prima perdevamo possiamo avere perciò
l'avventura all ultimo il tizio da
sfidare non è possibile soldi
nel caso vi steste chiedendo chi sta
perdendo tra i due in questo evento pio
x che lui ha più controllo sul cavo
facciamo così un rapporto è il tuo turno
lorenzo ciao questa ancora non mai
giocato
franco lorenzi è concentratissimo cioè
la tensione si aspetta con un coltello
bastava 108 a qualcuno che si salva al
11 da vedere ma porca di quella porta
vada bene le schede che questo casino
questo è molto carina un dio dio
facciamo questo qui
sembra molto interamente lo leviamo cosa
ma sei scemo scemo scemo tu sei scemo ma
non è vero
alberto la carta è scemo forte manovra
non è possibile come faccio a tenerli in
vita è praticamente di mira i prof
metti che ha pure provocazione arriva
sul furias in questo un problema non
dovevo avere 5 mar
ma io ragiono adesso sente di ragazzi
sono arrivato a completare la queste
quindi adesso questa cosa qua leva 8
danni a caso oa uno dei mostri che
metterà o a lui direttamente
e in più 4 di danno allora è tempo che
ha mattina in di conto che effetto
etnico 3 sticotti distruggere il nemico
sa cosa vuol dire così intanto
bellissima del servitore da domani
facciamo così ma come lo chiamava che
c'è il mazzo pil data forse c'è infatti
non capivo formato ma cosa sono i
tornado volgarmente si può fare quando
c'è un'altra brolin mano vergognoso un
cavaliere dell'amore ci arriva lascialo
in poi
basta con sto facendo cestari cavalieri
tante sit che non capisco
[ __ ] uno via l'altro a pregare
gesù e non sente meglio così non va bene
si stesse chiedendo nel caso chi sta
vincendo in questo punto forse io però
perché ho il potere se non sarebbe
bilanciato devo pensare però anche lui
ha un potere che non fa proprio schifo
intanto così via sono rigenerato solo
statura faccio vediamo
è riprendermi
chi mi vuole tutti scemi se dai dai che
la fortuna mi sorride arrivi adesso come
peccati restivo l'ultima è vero devo
pregare prosa preghiamo ma mi lasci in
pace
peccato the bene cosa fai primordi
alterino puoi fare che ansia
basta raga quanto è difficile vincere la
giorno d'oggi con questi youtuber vabbè
sempre più forti se youtubers big pro
gamers l'altro vi si vede si vede da
gioco così ciao
dai dai così questi carte giuste
cartesio massa come non è giusto non so
se farla non so se farlo non so se farla
non so se farò ma non lo farò non so se
letto bene no i morti al drake in
inglese tra l'aria bene però potresti
levarmi 15 di botto perché tutti gli
fuori mano c'è l'interessante non soft è
solo quella merda di mercato uno
scarabeo è questo che fa schifo io
pensavo che quindi sono tutti i miei
cavalieri con 4 ori e appaga la vista
e da tre armature spara su di me
va bene stefano stefani affanculo
adesso faccio io peccato non c'è una
soluzione è stata di scena
fate che figo e 05 37 torino sono finiti
a non c'è più servitori no il caso
cosentino
va bene la squadra diventa argento
logico liberali gente i danni sono the
last turno c'è nessuna carta che può
aiutarvi neanche una e allora non tease
non sorren daremo ridaro è vero come si
muore dai 9 sostanza dirò niente pace
niente riposo e va bene
come noto che devo fare
non si renda reparti notiamo civiltà
presa è quella carta che in mano che il
numero dove diavolo
ok questa è l'ultima montagna roste cd
ha deciso regnava su di lui a bad
manners pure no comment raga
vabbè dai dieci spettatori 10 sono fini
quelli della mia live forze principio
stiamo giocando a caldo la faccio con un
altro vai a fare un'altra io so solo
questo marzo però allora se vinco basta
se vinci tu la pensiamo alla bella e io
[Musica]
ti dico che gioco di nuovo questo perché
gli altri giuro io ho solo questo qua
purtroppo
[Musica]
mi chiedo ma sei quello vero
no non lo so vorrei rigioco questo
perché non non mi ricordo e mi ricordo
che gli altri mazzi quindi devo questo
primo sono partito con due stecco tonti
da sei in mano
madonna e quell'altra che da nuove che
ti cambia l'eroe dopo aver collegato le
carte secondo te però quanto dà fastidio
però con amore e morte vittoria ma
perché mi dedico sta bella in testa
tipici in testa altro che mettono
edificio in testa questo è che questa
prima carta che gioco e rella che dopo 7
mostri che un provocazione mi dà il
danno da due boss è fatto a posto io ho
pescato una carta devastante
io posso già sul rennes dare io tiro te
lo dico già con quello che in mano
passeggia sul rendere la partita non ho
niente ma niente nella vita proprio che
faccio che sono il più lontano possibile
alla vittoria i problemi anche tu hai
tutti i provocatori ma dopo che schifo
ma veramente
questa è una cosa non erano niente non
ti giuro per anche turno dopo in realtà
questo fa molto positivo se come muoio
prima vista mi ha raggiunto prima ok non
si tratta ma quando stai rivedranno poi
programmi cosa arriverà un paure dragano
no assolutamente
allora il tauren come si chiama in
inglese questa tar fighter e perché no
c'è un italiano perché il tuo computer
quindi non lo so sono in difficoltà pure
non ho niente in mano signori cossar e
anch'io so gestire la mia mano sono due
di queste sono trovate comunque le
schede le schede 322 non ha senso
chissà se faccio chissà
[Musica]
porco tuo sbagliato devo farlo prima
vabbè ragazzina uno sbaglio mai dato
basta che mi pare un altro ciccione dai
la 5 36 26
sono e meglio in questo che non lo so se
ho sbagliato la bolla adesso
l'acciaio sime d'italia meccaniche
l'inglese aaron forge credo se il buon
vecchio world of warcraft che in
italiano
limone giocato solo in english come i
veri tradizionalisti nella mia ora che
scavano da una parte per vincere sarà
una nuova espansione di warcraft quella
dove mettono l'espansione iniziale
avevo detto sì bellissimi aspetto solo
quello poi non faccia bene chiudo giorno
e notte li vai poco da fare il turno
scale e scale scale
l'unico che ho battuto uno che al dorso
leggendo attenzione non è mai successo
questo è tutto ciò che posso farlo dai
omino delle carte nostro punto antica
arte ios come non si chiama dalmazzo
sono effetti che non posso usare con i
droni e basta il tempo skele tipo di due
armature medievali da restar matura e
non sottostare ai userei
non lo so se non giocando un po su chi
va là perché ho pescato le carte
iniziali che non hanno senso di esistere
finalmente una carta che ha un senso
[Musica]
bello questo modo e serale in carte
locale cartello calde e birra che però
non c'è perché c'è ancora di osservarla
allora pacca delle cose punto da
fastidio spada
[Musica]
così la sta funzionando la tattica di
girare i monitor e non guardo il tuo
guardi sempre il serraglio di salvatore
scoca sfida una sola a perché ci vedo in
mano per che cosa fa ho capito hai hai
hai hai capito
basta che conosci effetto lo sai che se
no per scatolone perché per quello ma
non sai quali delle due nella ii in mano
è vero che quello questa è un ottima
osservazione come risolve questa partita
in realtà ora sono messo meglio di prima
e beh perché sono sincero non vinci
questa ciao qui a me vale soffrire in
cura per forza dai stefanino sii buono
con me per olivera lecce in hai tu sai
forse la spalla se ne stava meglio
tenerselo
cosa vuoi dalla vita mia gioca malizia
si vabbè 4 12 più un ostacolo
basta una carta per disturbare chi va
dall esecuzione l'unica carta che
potrebbe dire a prevedere la teoria
cinese e vaniglia picchiati di guccione
dai dai veleni i finiani ma è comunque
forte per comodo è prescindere dal fatto
di avere un 4 12
la questione che schifo maledizione ma
che si tratta di quelle cose era
veramente brutto sì gli altri non si
regala niente
sì diciamo così fosse una serviva prova
va bene un import questo cubo cardine
l'anno l'espansione vero si sarà
l'accordo sto improvvisando mi ammalo
caso stamattina quindi non lo conosco
molto bene ma va via un sacco di carte
in mano man e c'è un sacco di male io
d'amore buono a lui faccia mio stimolo
vabbè però combattuta nonostante sia
partita male almeno un battuta va in
meno neanche se carina ma basta al d
basta sta roba
poi andare a cagare non dico ti metto un
altro un'altra regola perché mai a
finire male mi sento con le due risse
infami tengo a sicure su quattro è
rimasta quella magari ha contribuito a
farmi perdere
[Musica]
dove finiranno gli otto danni
spero vivamente sul 11 vai
no perché come noto ha beccato da
beccare maledizione è mica roba che sta
roba qua va da questa casa muori insetto
sensi per sicurezza
niente adesso vinceremo tutte trovate la
ricordate maggiori quanto da anni che
spero non cada prossimo cazzo ma sono un
[ __ ] noti altri lorenzo se si
volesse per fare di sicuro madonna mi
faccia da face quindi non so se ho
sbagliato lo so ipad è quello per me è
un grosso problema quindi non so come
comportarmi alle rago che non ha niente
togliermelo imposto alla salute da
versare a 1 imposta l'attacco dei nemici
a1 alle caste da paladino e non ce l'ho
le carte del paladino fate non so come
fare perché il paladino annuncia questa
volta il martello lungo dai
proprio il massimo della vita un posto
all'altro tutta quella carta che
ricambia la partita completamente
infatti i primordi al drink ho giocato
io ne hai un altro
ciao amici a questo punto non so se
morte in faccia che cosa vuoi fare scusa
che la partita malissimo sta partita noi
pare in generale in questo mazzo di tuo
funzioni ma è l'unico che mi ricordava
un pochettino gli altri numeri ricordava
nemmeno data per assistere quanto un
turno poi l'amore
la ex quegli otto danni cadono nel punto
sbagliato supporto la mia partita perde
su questo stai facendo stanno
inquadrando malissimo
è successo qua nel frattempo chimica
pellico sto bene e se buono
e c'hanno abel settimana lancia facesse
ridere ma c'è grande attesa
beh scusa è questa l'unica te ce del mio
mazzo se permetti una ce n'è una che c'è
ma gesù stai calmo calmati uno mi ha
scritto gesù sangue io basta secondo me
perde questa partita è in sala vj benda
ho bisogno di vita datemi la spada che
mi aiuta la vita è vinto scende di
capire come sbagliare questa mossa show
porta come la voglio sbagliare in quel
modo puoi sbagliare la passa bene
non so se mi conviene fare questo però
penso di porca la prima né il tuo sono
rimaste la peta
sarà che la cina considera la sola non
serve la cina senza voce
ma solo pensare però che vergogna ho
sbagliato a quella venuta anche elogiato
le ho già fatto tutto scegliere uno a
caso tra il tra quelli che mi erano
capitati dimostri uno a caso il mancino
terra una grande disperazione
comunque adesso
ma che riesce a vincere la cuesta al
rapporto marinai una carta o meno
decente
mica non te lo leggo neanche pensate o
che disastro aiuto dovevamo levato non
sparare quegli otto da anni su di me
e noi invece conviene che gli spazi che
gli spari su di te le carte rai
quante carte ai guanti calze usando
questo pensiamo noi
che schifo e non so cosa fare perché
questo è quanto remota ma dopo andare
così appariva preghiamo skype skype
skype non so non so non so se ho fatto
bene se è rimasta uno di vita per
rompere ha veramente senso farla e nella
riempire il campo dimostri adesso è la
cosa migliore da fare
oddio no basta che non rimanga il
provocazione o mio dio rosso come se non
a lei prova che azzerava in più avremmo
via no pro vinto lo stesso perché se lo
faccio fuori
[Musica]
dai stata una maga un serio l'altro ma
su scorrette ma quale quadro ma non è
vero
però però ho sudato fortissimo senso è
stato fortissimo di rissa rissa vediamo
un po cosa distrugge oggi la carta più
forte il mio mazzo ragazzo questo sta
sbloccando adesso chiudila dai ragazzi
speriamo che il video vi sia piaciuto e
ho avuto curano serie ho avuto culo
perché in genere di stefano mi fa il
miracolo che ci è riuscito a vincere due
volte giuro in realtà non vinco mai e
non sto scherzando nemo per dirlo è vero
non fa caldo di dentro con caldo bestia
a caldo ma io sono in sciopero
ufficialmente tra l'altro così sembra
anche più basso di quanti ragazzi
speriamo che lei vi sia piaciuta
lasciatemi pjanic enunciate mi piace e
per provare l'espansione nuova di
hurston i link in descrizione e noi
speriamo che la rai vi sia piaciuto se
non sono mesi sto paura si ricorda a
chiamarsi sarebbe carente da casa ma è
pagato qua dice che sono il live da 57
minuti ma i fake siamo hillary da molte
di più la morte pienezza tra le nove
sono le undici quasi due ore perché
quando si segna poco
sono scemo io ai ragazzi speriamo che
viene vissuto come seguito seguirà
preciso momento è un bel like anche la
lista cioè comino statale scrizione mica
stefano partecipato trovate il canale di
stefano in descrizione al micron
io sono un professionista microfono
tengo ancora qui non in alto va bene
anche così non siamo bravi gemini santa
di mashhad